first of all how are you enjoying this
golden globe experience
ah it's fantastic you know really i
oh yeah i couldn't imagine that you know
it wasn't expected and uh
i'm taking advantage of every second so
it's cool i know it's too bad we're not
over there in america meeting people and
talking face to face but uh
it's all right you know it's great okay
so where are you right now
in paris wow what time is it in paris
uh 10 past midnight okay gotta
see that means you're going to be up
pretty late to wait for your category
oh yeah it's about it it'll be around 4
4 30 or something so yeah i'll be
exhausted but uh but it's exciting
how do you plan on celebrating if you
win tonight
how do you plan on celebrating oh man
i don't know i don't know but i mean if
it happens i'm gonna have a i might have
a little drink with my friends who are
here
and you know celebrating but wait a
minute so you
you have a crew that's there i got a
couple of friends on another room
waiting they wanted to see it and share
this moment with
me so uh it's always good how does it
feel to be nominated uh
among so many legends like anthony
hopkins gary oldman and even um the late
chadwick boseman is in that group
i don't know it's uh i mean man it's
crazy i couldn't even imagine that it
could happen someday
is there anything in particular you're
looking forward to from the show
tonight how do you think it'll be with
two um hosts on two coasts
uh i know they're very they're very
funny so
i'm waiting uh for them to you know to
make some jokes and have fun and
yeah i want to see jody win is that your
red carpet outfit did you still get
dressed up tonight
yeah i got this uh dark blue
suit from louis vuitton and some uh a
pair of
hot city shiny boots oh model it you got
to model it you got to give us something
yeah yeah give us a stand up give us a
little
give us a little red carpet okay all
right
here it is all right move the chair move
the chair you gotta move the chair
so you got the black buttons dark blue
and the boots nice
i love them thank you so much and listen
thank you for zooming with us i know i
mean it's a nerve-wracking moment but
and we're trying to get our world
together too so
thanks so much thank you thank you for
your time man okay